president trump i didn't even know he
had scheduled this
but he had scheduled
a press conference
for the anniversary of january 6th
and had i known that he had done that i
would have advised him to cancel the
press conference but didn't even need to
because he already canceled it he
sent out a memo you can't say he tweeted
anymore because he got booted from
twitter but he sends out these press
releases which are just tweets
and then he sends them out and then
people tweet the pictures of them so
this is what he said
in light of the total bias and
dishonesty of the january 6th the
unselect committee of democrats
because they're not they're not the
highest selection
two failed republicans and the fake news
media i am canceling the january 6th
press conference at mar-a-lago on
thursday and instead we'll discuss many
of those important topics at my rally on
saturday january 15th in arizona i look
forward to seeing our great american
patriots in arizona next weekend for a
big rally to save america
totally the right thing to do donald
trump maybe you hate the guy maybe you
love the guy
donald trump understands politics and he
understands stagecraft
and he understands when he's in a
winning situation where he can get a big
win and he understands when you're in a
situation and you can't get a win
the way the libs have framed january 6th
is a complete loser
you can't win if you play into it and so
he recognized this and he said okay
never mind whatever we're gonna have
january 15th that's going to be the new
big day and we're gonna have a big rally
and we're gonna talk about how great
america is and we're not going to buy
into their nonsense and the myriad lies
that they told about what actually
happened at the capitol lies such as the
the rioters killing a police officer
brian sicknick with it was just
completely made up so yeah we're going
to ignore that we're just going to move
on
he had the right idea we should follow
course because donald trump knows a
thing or two about politics he knows a
whole lot about stagecraft and show
business and he's right and he's looking
pretty good right now by the way
i don't know if you've been paying
attention to the current occupant of the
oval office
but he's not
particularly popular i'm so glad you
like that clip welcome to my humble
abode
welcome to the inner sanctum if you want
more insight like this if you want more
special glimpses into what's going on in
my mind
in my home then i would strongly
recommend you
ring that bell
subscribe get those notifications head
on over to apple podcast but if i stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you